Alte Taten, ein Wurm in meinem Ohr, Alte Taten, ein ganzer Bömerachor, Alte Taten, schuld ist der Florentin, Alte Taten, dunkel schnur wir ihn hin. Podcast Ufo, jetzt geht es endlich los mit Florentin und Stefan. müssen, aber wir bitten, in Intros von Todesdrohungen abzusehen. Es ist ja ein Todesurteil quasi. Ich bin jetzt zum Tode verurteilt. Wir richten ihn hin, so eine Ankündigung von Taten, auf deren Umsetzung erstmal abzuwarten bleiben zu können. Ja, ich habe gar nicht so viel Interesse, darauf zu warten. Ich werde untertauchen. Ich tauche unter. Wohin würdest du untertauchen? Ich würde komplett untertauchen. Wohin, sag mal? In Keller. Ich würde untertauchen in irgendeinen verlassenen Keller. In Süddeutschland bin ich unterwegs. Und den würde ich präventiv schon mal komplett mit Wasser fluten und dann einfach ein Leben unter Wasser genießen, ähnlich wie Sebastian. Unter dem Meer, unter dem Wasserspiegel im Keller. Die Krabbe Sebastian wird mein Vorbild sein. RAF Sebastian, wie man ja auch sagt, der ist ja untergetaucht, der wurde nie gefasst. Wer hat denn das Intro gemacht, wer würde dich dann da hängen? Der liebe Kevin hat das Intro gemacht, ganz fantastisch Alte Daten, ein Klassiker mittlerweile, ist mittlerweile eigentlich auf allen The Best of Punk-Alben-Zusammenstellungen zu finden, aber auch The Best of Classic, Alte Daten, ist einfach gut, man kann es immer wieder gerne singen, es wird sowohl als Einschlaflied gesungen, als auch als Aufweglied. Vier Leute haben das als Handy-Klingelton mittlerweile. Mir gefällt es, wenn ich in der U-Bahn, ich muss immer ein bisschen lächeln, wenn ich in der U-Bahn sitze, vertieft in meinen Schopenhauer und dann höre ich auf dem Kindel und dann höre ich auf der anderen Seite die sprichwörtlichen Kinder dann irgendwie und ich denke mir so, wenn ihr wüsstet, wer hier mit euch in eurer Kabine sitzt. Was, warum? Wenn ihr wüsstet, wüsstet. Ich meine, so muss es Robbie Williams gehen. Du sitzt einfach da, Robbie Williams, Robin Williams auch. Du sitzt einfach da und die Leute singen Millennium und dann läuft man vorbei auf dem Weg zum Bordbistro und dann, wie geht man damit um? Nickt man einmal zu, sagt man ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne Hast du den neuen Film von ihm gesehen, Better Man? Nein, leider nicht, ich habe dieses Jahr die Oscar-Season komplett verpasst, wir müssen eh über die Oscars reden. Müssen wir dringend. Ich habe ganz bewusst keinen einzigen Oscar-Film angeschaut, um mich nicht spoilern zu lassen für den Oscar-Abend, ich liebe Oscar-Abend, ich ziehe mich an, ich habe den Frack an, ich stelle mir selbst Interviewfragen, den roten Teppich rolle ich aus und dann Who are you wearing, what are you wearing, what is wearing, what are you carrying, also was hast du auf den Schultern. Und dann überlege ich mir gute Snappy-Antworten und dann schlafe ich meistens nach der zweiten Kategorie mit einem Bauch voller Kit-Kat ein. Ihr hört übrigens das Podcast-Ufo. Das hat Kevin bereits gesagt. Das ist ein Podcast-Projekt, was es nun schon ein bisschen länger gibt. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass, obwohl wir immer wieder rotieren, dass du und ich heute zusammengekommen sind. Wir haben ein sehr komplexes Rotationsverfahren, wo wir uns selber manchmal verwickeln. Und dann tauchen wir hier auf im Studio und dann, ach, du warst heute gar nicht dran, das ist immer peinlich, unangenehm. Man ist extra eingeschneit, eingeflogen und dann muss man unverrichteter Ding wieder nach Hause gehen. Aber trotzdem, vielen, vielen Dank an Kevin. Und meine Güte, wie viele Oscar-Seasons haben wir schon in diesem Podcast hier besprochen? Also ich erinnere mich an Colin Firth, The King's Speech, Natalie Pawson, Lake Swan und das waren wirklich tolle Filme. Civil Inings Playbook, The Green Book, The Hurt Locker, meine Güte, wie heisst er? Little Women, Ach Women, ach was war das für eine Oscarsaison. A Place beyond the Pines. The Artist. The Artist on the Lake, on the Reflecting of the Sea Sun. Three Artists outside Lewin, Missouri, das war ein ... Mooncrashingsland. Ja, fantastisch. Und wir lieben Filme, wir lieben Filme, wir lieben die Welt, wir lieben die Gala, wir lieben die Celebs. Und gestern muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, waren die Oscars, wir sind ein transparenter Podcast, wir nehmen nicht erst auf, zwei Stunden bevor ihr diese Folge hört. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das machen andere, das machen wir nicht. Deswegen haben wir die ja noch ein bisschen präsenter, die Oscars jetzt. Ich bin so ein bisschen unzufrieden. Weil die Statue kein Glied hat, oder warum? Gut, also ich frage mich halt, dann mach eine Unterhose. Genau, das denke ich mir auch. Ich denke, ich mache entweder Unterhose, sichtbar, oder zeige das verdammte Glied. Aber nicht diese Ken-artige Zwischenwelt. Wir können nicht so tun, als würden die sich nicht konstant fortpflanzen Backstage, diese Oscar-Statuetten. Und einfach auch wirklich der menschlichen Anatomie treu bleiben. Und deswegen forderst du ja, du bist ja im Deutschen Drehbuchverband, dem DSBB-EVG. EV, ja. Und jetzt forderst du Herr mit dem Glied. Ja, ich, ja, also zu meiner Unzufriedenheit setze ich das immer wieder aufs Protokoll, auf die Tagesordnung und es wird immer so ein bisschen wegignoriert, also das Gefühl, da haben viele die Dringlichkeit noch nicht verstanden.
Woher kommt die Dringlichkeit genau? Weil das habe ich auch noch nicht ganz verstanden.
Wieso? Hast du jemals diese Oscar-Statue? Ist der Ostkater, stolze Oscars, stolzer, goldener Phallus-Mann.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum der kein pralles Glied hat.
Ja, okay, aber du meinst, das ist natürlich eine interessante Beobachtung, der Mann, der selbst der Phallus ist, hat dann selber keinen Phallus mehr. Genau, aber das ist eine Entmännlichung des Oscars. Ja, also ich bin da wirklich dran, aber wie gesagt, da werden die Zeichen der Zeit noch nicht ganz begriffen, mal wieder nicht ganz begriffen. Mein Problem ist halt, wenn du eine Unterhose machst, dann legst du dich natürlich modisch fest. Der Oscar ist natürlich eine Statuette, die Jahrzehnte, Jahrtausend überdauern muss. Trägt der Boxer-Briefs, Boxer-Trunks, Boxer-Tram-Slips, Slips, kann sich ein Slip. Man weiß es nicht genau, in welche Richtung es da geht. Boxer-Shorts. Weil da hat sich ja einiges getan, auch in der Unterwäschewelt, muss man es ganz ehrlich sagen. Ja. Und da sind ja wirklich Revolutionen auf dem Startblock, die sich mittlerweile anbahnen.
Ich habe damals zu meiner Erschütterung diese weiten Opa-Boxer-Shorts getragen, weil das damals cool war, en vogue war. Damals erinnere ich mich wirklich an Situationen in der Umkleide, Sportumkleide generell. Lass das, also lasst doch, das ist wirklich ein reines Parading der Leute, die einen guten normalen Körper haben. Ich, der damals auch untersetzt war, dann meine Trichterbrust hatte, für mich war das einfach Horror. Und deswegen, du willst dann da nicht rausfallen, deswegen trägst du dann das, was die Gesellschaft gebietet.
Das waren dann diese weiten Boxershorts. Ich glaube, deswegen hat es sich auch durchgesetzt, dass man Sportkleidung im Alltag trägt. So Sneakers oder Jogginghose ist ja Sportkleidung. Damit man sich gar nichts umziehen muss. Damit man sich nicht umziehen muss. Das war einfach so, ach nee, das ist mein normaler Kleidungsziel, ich muss mich nicht umziehen. Aber ich habe auch die langen Boxershorts getragen und dann immer, wenn man die Hose angezogen hat, haben die sich so hochgerollt. Wie so ein Ballon. Also sich so hochgerollt, so dass du immer so komische Streifen hattest unter der Hose und dann musste ich immer in die Hose rein und die nochmal so sortieren.
Ja, dann macht man so, sortiert man so.
Ganz unangenehm.
Ja, und dann gibt es so Fotos von mir, wie auch mein, ich auch immer schon ein bisschen zu groß, meine T-Shirts immer schon ein bisschen zu klein und zu kurz, dann wie dann so ein Ballon so über meiner Hose, die man damals noch tiefer getragen hat, dann kommt aus der Hose wirklich so ein Ballon-Boxershort raus. Also, dass das mal irgendwann wirklich die Mode war, finde ich schwierig. Ist ja eh, dass man sich relativ willkürlich auf diese Zahl zwei festgelegt hat, zwei Schichten, Unterhose, Überhose. Warum nicht drei, warum nicht vier, wo sind die verschiedenen Abstufungen, die man da eingehen kann, dass man sagt, unter der Unterhose nochmal eine etwas kleinere Unterhose, die man dann sozusagen als Sicherheitsmechanismus nochmal drunter platziert. Fände ich auch nicht schlecht. So wie ... Ja, ich bin der Meinung, der Oscar, der würde keine Unterhose tragen. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Wenn du Oscar bist. Oscar gibt Kommando. Glatzköpfig, du bist wirklich ein praller Mensch, stehst irrigiert dort. Ich glaube nicht, dass du da irgendeine Badehose anziehen würdest. Da schaue ich euch an, Drehbuchverband, ich schaue euch an, German Film. Ich erwarte, dass da ein bisschen was passiert. Ich finde, eine offensichtliche Sache, die man noch machen könnte, wäre natürlich, weil, sind wir ehrlich, wir schauen die Oscarverleihung, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, ich will Timothy Chalamet sehen. Was mich nicht interessiert, ist Best Make-Up, Best Sound Boom Operator, Best Grip Boy. Zeig mir Best Timothy Chalamet. Ja, so, jedes Jahr will ich ihn sehen. Und was man da machen könnte, wäre für Bestes Kostüm, zieh dem Oscar das Kostüm an, wofür er den Oscar gewinnt. Also wenn du sagst, Bestes Kostüm ist Wicked, dann hat die Oscar-Statue auch so ein Hexen-Outfit an. Super. Weil dann kann man auch als dummer Zuschauer direkt sehen, ah, das ist das Kostüm, um das es geht, weil ich habe keine Ahnung, was genau die Kunst eines Kostümbildners ist und so würde ich direkt sehen, ah, und natürlich die Blöße in den meisten Fällen, in den meisten Kostümen bedeckt. Ja, da wäre ich dann wiederum gegen, also ich finde, ziehe den ruhig das Kostüm an, aber bedeckt den nicht. Okay, also dann würdest du natürlich auch einschränken. Oder zeig zumindest, dass er gut ausgestattet ist oder so. Ja, okay, ja. Gestern, genau, für eine der Überraschungen, Wicked hast du im Kostüm gewonnen. Nee, ich glaube, das war keine Überraschung, das haben wir alle gesehen. Hast du den Film gesehen? Der Spitzehut. Wir waren ja im Musical in New York, heißt die Stadt, haben wir das gesehen. Auch da habe ich schon gehustet. Das stimmt. Du hast mich extrem angesteckt. Das war ganz furchtbar. In den letzten Wochen waren extrem schlimm für mich. Wir wissen es nicht, wie es passiert ist. Die Dudes sind auch krank. Alle krank. Ich habe alle angesteckt, wirklich um mich herum. Ich ziehe alle in eine Aura des Verfalls und des Siegtums. Es tut mir wirklich leid. Ich bin wirklich wie so ein Treibsand, der alles nach unten zieht und ich bin einfach ein schlechter Einfluss und es tut mir auch leid. Ja, nee, also deswegen, sorry, dass ich noch nicht so richtig auf der Höhe bin. Nee, sorry, ich glaube, wir kommen auch nie wieder auf die Höhe zurück. Nee, jetzt werden wir uns gegenseitig immer anstecken. Es ist ein Ansteckungspingpong und irgendwann merkt man auch, man war einfach
vielleicht nie auf der Höhe oder man kommt einfach
nie mehr auf die Höhen, auf die man war. Ich habe
unfassbar viel Ingwer konsumiert.
Ich dachte, Ingwer ist konserviert.
In mir
fermentiert es gerade vor sich hin.
Unfassbar viel Ingwer,
ganz schwer auch zu schälen,
zu benutzen, irgendwann war ich
wirklich stocksauer.
Offensichtlich. Das Schlimmste ist ja, wenn du nachts Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,len, zu benutzen, irgendwann war ich wirklich stocksaure. Das ist großartige Zunge weggebrannt, offensichtlich.
Das Schlimmste ist ja, wenn du nachts eine Nacht durchkommen musst und nicht die ganze Nacht husten willst, dann dachte ich mir, komm, mach dir so eine schöne Thermoskanne mit Ingwer-Tee. Ja, mach da schön heisses Wasser rein in die Thermoskanne, schneid dir wirklich zwei, zwei, drei Knubbelzehen, Ingwer, Zitrone da rein und dann leg das hin und dann schlaf ein und dann kannst du irgendwie nachts, falls du husten musst, Hustenanfall, ganz viel daraus trinken. Und dann schläfst du halt so deine dreieinhalb Stunden, öffnest diese Thermoskanne und merkst mal, was eigentlich so zweieinhalb Ingwerknollen mit so einem halben Liter Wasser anrichten, wenn du das dann ziehst und auf Ex trinken willst und du einfach denkst, du hast einfach Bleiche im Mund, einfach wirklich Chlor-Entferner, einfach Dr. Proper im Mund und es zieht dir einfach alles aus dem Körper zusammen und zu dem Hustenanfall, den du eh schon kurieren willst, hast du dann auch noch einen Säureanfall, du spuckst hustend wieder diese Ingwersäure aus. Und Blut. Und Blut, alles zersetzt sich, dein Kopfkissen ist voller Blut, Galle, schwarzer Galle, roter Galle, Ingwergalle, alles durch und dann ist die Nacht eigentlich auch gelaufen. Dann ist die Nacht gelaufen. Es ist wie so eine zickende Zeitbombe, die neben deinem Bett steht und der Ingwer denkt sich, Leute, langsam müssen wir getrunken werden, oder? Das nimmt wirklich wie so schweres Wasser, so radioaktives Wasser, was einfach irgendwann kritisch wird, in so einen instabilen Zustand gerät. Und man sagt, Leute, irgendwann muss es losgehen. Aber das ist verrückt. Ja, übrigens, wo du von radioaktivem Wasser sprichst, auf meiner Dschungelreise waren auch Osteuropäer am Start. Ich meine aus Polen. Und die hatten, und das fand ich so irgendwie on brand, aber hatten so radioaktive Wasserflaschen. Also da war Strahlung drin und das hat dann das Wasser, was man sich aus dem Fluss geholt hat, irgendwie gereinigt und haben das getrunken. Aber ich fand, für mich war das so on brand, weil ich bin an denen vorbeigelaufen irgendwann zu meinem Bankbett und kam an diesen Polen vorbei, die Leuten diese Flasche gezeigt haben und gesagt haben, well, this is radiation. We drink this every day. This is a bit radiation to make the water clean. Plutonium, 36. A little bit radiation never hurt. A little bit of uranium, a little bit of plutonium, radiation, mix and do whatever. Womit mal, hast du drei Flaschen in der Hand, hast du drei Hände? Was ist hier los? So lustig, weil das war wie so ein Sketch. Natürlich kommt dann der Ukrainer mit seinem Tschernobyl-Plutonium-Water. Und ja, ich habe es nicht probiert.
Ich hatte da große Angst vor, vor dieser Flasche,
die dann nachts immer so ein Neon-Grün geheuchtet hat.
Aber das fand ich nicht schlecht.
Geil.
Von daher, so war es vielleicht auch gut.
Ich habe das nicht gemacht mit Ingwer,
ich bin kein großer Fan von Ingwer,
ich habe schon auch Tee getrunken, bin aber Räubusch-Fan.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht klassischer Erkältungstee. Ich habe eh überlegt, man müsste ganz viele Experimente machen, weil ich weiß nahezu nichts. Ich glaube, die wurden alle schon gemacht. Na, zum Thema, wie viel Tee ist Tee? Also, gibt es Max-Tee, maximalen Tee? Also wenn du jetzt wirklich, sagen wir mal, du machst eine Teetasse mit fünf Teebeuteln und dann machst du noch eine Teetasse mit fünfzig Teebeuteln und dann machst du noch eine Teetasse mit fünfhundert Teebeuteln. Gibt es da Unterschiede oder ist einfach irgendwann das Maximum erreicht und jeder weitere Teebeutel hat dann keinen weiteren Effekt mehr? Aber weisst du, ob Frage ist? Also, du machst einen Tee. Du machst einen Teebeutel
ins Wasser,
heißes Wasser, so.
Alles klar. Jetzt nimmst du da raus,
zum Beispiel mit Hitze, das Wasser weg.
Was bleibt dann
über? Nur H2O
nimmst du weg. Aus dem Tee.
Was bleibt dann über?
Ja, der reine Tee quasi.
Jetzt meine Frage an dich.
Was ist das?
T-Satz, T-irgendwas? Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Deswegen meine ich, da müssen noch ganz viele Fragen beantwortet werden. Und ich bin dabei. Und wir haben das T-Reddit übernommen, wir haben wirklich einige Truppen versammelt, wir haben expandiert, wir haben das Personal. Warum greift dann die, also wir müssen jetzt auch dieses Personal, das wir in einem menschenverachtenden Angriffskrieg erobert haben, dieses Gebiet, das wir erobert haben, müssen wir jetzt eigentlich auch nutzen. Das T-Reddit, wir haben es den T-Shirt, ja, Faschos abgekämpft und haben es jetzt in die demokratischen Hände der deutschen T-Community übergeben. Und da müssen wir jetzt auch was machen, weil da will ich jetzt auch mal wirklich Antworten haben. Deutsche Subreddits sind Deutschen. Nach dem Motto haben wir jetzt das Tee-Subreddit übernommen. Genau. Ich möchte das aber kurz zu Ende denken. Und bitte nicht nachdenken, sondern einfach intuitiv antworten. Alles klar. Gut. Nochmal. Wir machen einen starken Tee. Wir nehmen das Wasser weg und Teebeutel auch weg. Was bleibt über? Teesatz, hast du gerade gesagt. Teesatz, ja. Teessenz. Das multiplizieren, das machen wir mit 50 Tassen 50 Mal. Das schütten wir alles zusammen. Was bleibt über? Tee. Reinster TNT-Tee. Das machen wir jetzt in einen Teebeutel rein und machen damit einen Tee. Ich glaube, das ist der beste, leckerste Tee der Welt. Ja, das kann schon sein. Oder, kennst du diesen Granulat-Tee? Ja, Krümel-Tee, ja klar. Oder ist das das? Das kann auch sein, dass da einfach wirklich kesselweise Tee runtergekocht wird und dann am Ende dieser Krümel-Tee übrig wird. Tee-Sirup ist es doch. Im Grunde, wenn es geht, ich weiß es nicht. Was ist Sirup? Wo ist die Konzentration? Sirup ist sehr viel Zucker mit schönem Geschmack drin. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, Zucker ist auch noch so ein Ding. Aber das ist für mich jedes Problem, ab wann ist zu viel, weil da muss ja irgendwann zu viel sein. Oder ist dann irgendwann übernimmt dann, ist es dann mehr Ingwer als Wasser. Und es ist wieder fast wieder Ingwer auf der Seite.
Weil in Ingwer ist ja auch Wasser drin.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt in dieser Thermosflasche die Ingwerkonzentration so hoch ist,
dass es fast schon wieder Ingwer ist und gar kein Tee mehr,
kann es kippen in die andere Richtung.
Mir wurde als Kind eingetrichtert von denen da oben,
dass der Mensch irgendwie zu 80 Prozent aus Wasser besteht. Richtig, ja. Dann die Erde. Die Gurke aus 90%, Salat fast 95%. Die Qualle aus 99%. Wasser besteht auch zu 80% aus Wasser. Glaube ich auch. Die Erde besteht zu, weißt du nicht, 80% aus Wasser. So, jetzt kommen wir alle zusammen kurz. I call bullshit. Ja, endlich. Ingwer ist Wasser. Ingwer ist kein Wasser. Einmutiger, der es ausspricht. Ingwer ist Ingwer. Mensch ist Mensch. Die Erde ist Stein. Es ist Stein. Gurke ist eine Gurke. Qualle ist Quallen. Ich finde das sehr, sehr gut, dass endlich mal jemand was ausspricht gegen dieses Wasserdiktat. Weil letzten Endes, was heißt denn da ist Wasser drin? Vor allem ist es ja auch nicht Teil des Wassers. Wenn du einen Stein hast, dann ist da auch Wasser drin. Deswegen darf man Steine, die man so findet im Flussbett nicht erhitzen, sonst platzen die. Aber es ist ja deswegen kein Wasserstein, es ist ein Stein, der halt nass ist. Ich finde, wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen Dinge, die nass sind und Dinge, die aus Wasser bestehen. Weil klar, wir leben nun mal in einer Luftfeuchtigkeitswelt. Frage, sind Fische immer nass? Ja. Ich finde nicht. Fische sind nicht nass. Etwas, was im Wasser existiert, nass. Aber wenn du einen Fisch aus dem Wasser holst, dann ist der nass. Ja, gebe ich dir recht. Im Wasser nicht. Nein. Also damit etwas nass sein muss, muss es auch die Trockenheit als Kontrast daneben existieren. Exakt. Nass ist in einer trockenen Welt die Abwesenheit von Trockenheit oder das Nicht-Trockene. Nass ist das Nicht-Trockene. Ich habe jetzt einen Hydrometer zu Hause, wo immer die Temperatur angezeigt wird und die Luftfeuchtigkeit. Was würdest du denn denken, was so eine normale Luftfeuchtigkeit ist in einem Raum? In Prozent? Also jetzt mal, wenn du sagst, ganz normaler Raum. Ich weiß genau, dass die uns da oben jetzt wieder einreden wollen, dass die Luft ist Wasser. Wir sind basic unter Wasser. Wir wachsen gleich Kiemen. Ja. Ja, ich glaube wirklich hoch. Also ich glaube sowas wie 70 Prozent. Ja, 70 war schon hoch, so 60 Prozent. Moment. Und da steht beim Hydrometer. Stimmt ja nicht. Ja, weiss man nicht. Doch, doch. Ja, exakt. Muss ich hier rumschwimmen? Ja, im Grunde könntest du hier schwimmen in dem Raum. Was heißt denn 60% Luftfeuchtigkeit? Ich glaube, das ist 60% der maximalen Luftfeuchtigkeit, die die Luft haben kann. Und bei 100% ist ... 100% ist gesättigt, da kann die Luft kein Wasser mehr aufnehmen. Aber selbst im Regen atmischer Sauerstoff. Ja, okay. Aber das Coole an meinem Hydrometer ist, dass da ... Dass man es wegwerfen kann. Dass man es wegwerfen kann, wenn man mit den Ergebnissen unzufrieden ist. Man kann einfach sagen, sie bringen mir jetzt gleich mal nochmal neue Ergebnisse, 60% ist viel zu viel, raus. Und neben dem, und das finde ich eigentlich sollte immer bei jedem Messinstrument daneben stehen, da steht die Luftfeuchtigkeit und daneben steht ein Smiley. Wie, und der Smiley Mir gefällt nicht, dass mir das Hydreter sagt, was gut ist für mich. Mir gefällt das nämlich schon. Weil wenn er jetzt stünde, luftfeuchtige 60 Prozent, weiß ich nicht, okay, muss ich jetzt aufpassen, bin ich im kritischen Zustand. Aber der Smiley sagt mir, freundlich lächelndes Smiley. Über 60 Prozent wird der Smiley so, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, ist die Auflösung? Ich habe mir vorgestellt, du hast so zwei Punkte und Klammer zu. Es ist so dieses Display, wo manche Dinge manchmal leuchten und manchmal nicht. Das heißt, du siehst auch immer den Frowny, aber der leuchtet nicht, sondern nur der Smiley leuchtet. Aber der Frowny ist immer da. Was ist ein Frowny? Wenn er traurig guckt. Ach so. Statt Smiley-Frowny. Ah, man sieht immer den ... Man sieht das immer schon. Ah, ja, ja. Deswegen, das Lächeln ist auch ganz weit oben, unter den Augen, und das Frowny ist ganz weit unten, damit der Abstand ist. Ich weiß nicht, wie man diese Technologie nennt, aber ... Ja, acht Bit. Acht Bit. So, sagen wir mal, acht, neun Bit, so zwischen acht und zehn. Wusstest du, dass acht Bit zu neun, dass besonders Wasser besteht? Die ersten sechs Bit sind eigentlich komplett Wasser. Habe ich jetzt übrigens kurzer Zwischeneinschub gesehen, fand ich mega interessant. Es gibt ja überall diese schrecklichen Einweg-Vapes. Und die gibt es jetzt mit dem Tamagotchi drin. Und zwar musst du es am Leben herhalten. Zwei schlechte Erfindungen zusammen sind wieder eine gute. Die Idee ist, du musst, das ist eine geniale Idee des Herstellers, du musst dran ziehen, damit das Wesen überlebt. Jetzt habe ich überlegt, eine Anti-Rauch-Kampagne, also eine Rauch-Entwöhnungskampagne, das Gegenteil. Du machst ein Klamagocci, was auch ein Einweg-Vape ist, aber das Klamagocci sieht aus, also dieses Wesen sieht aus wie deine Lunge, Lungi oder so. Und das ist so eine süße Lunge mit grossen Augen, grosse, kleine, süße Augen. Ist eine Herausforderung, Charakter-Design-mäßig, eine Lunge jetzt süss aussehen zu lassen? Naja, einfach diese zwei Flügel und dann so grosse Comic-Augen, die dich immer so anblinzeln. Okay, wo ist der Mund? Hat keinen Mund. Ah, okay. Und wenn du rauchst, geht's dir schlechter. Also wenn du daran ziehst, geht's dir schlechter. Du gewöhnst dir so langsam das Rauchen ab, damit es dir besser geht. Weil du Mitleid hast mit Lungi. Exakt. Okay, finde ich gut. Aber was ist die Story dahinter, hinter diesen Vapes? Also ist die Idee, du saugst den Rauch dem Tamagotchi weg, sodass der frei ist, oder warum ist der unglücklich, wenn du nicht vapest? Du meinst beim Rauchhersteller? Was ist die Law? Wie sieht das Intro aus? Also ich stelle mir vor, der steht in so einem Raum, wo alles voller Rauch ist. Und in dem Moment, in dem du saugst, saugst du den Rauch aus dem Gerät raus und der Tamagotchi ist ... Dann konnotierst du ja den Rauch mit etwas Schlechtem. Ja, aber das kannst du als Zigarettenersteller nicht machen. Aber in dem Moment, in dem, wenn du ziehst, es dem gut geht, ist es ja konnotiert als, ich befreie den vom Rauch. Na, oder ... Aber wie ist die Lore? Ich finde dich so cool, wenn du rauchst. Ich bin so glücklich, wenn du rauchst. Nee, das reicht mir nicht als Story-Arc. Die Lore ist auch nicht gut. Die Lore ist echt wirklich überhaupt nicht gut. Ich meine nur, ich finde die Idee, erst mal etwas so Banales mit etwas Spielerischem zu kombinieren, erst mal nicht schlecht. Mir gefällt nur nicht, wie die es machen. Also du würdest dann sagen, kauf unsere Zigaretten, weil damit hörst du auf zu rauchen, weil da ist ein Tamagotchi drin, der selber gerne raucht und wenn du rauchst, ziehst du dem den Rauch weg und dann ist der wiederum traurig. Wie gesagt, Lunge, keine Lunge, die langsam stirbt, wenn du rauchst. Mein Problem ist ja, in dem Moment, in dem du nicht rauchst, bleibt der Rauch in der Zigarette drin und dann geht es der Lunge ja schlecht. Nee, nee. Du musst, also ich finde, man muss das andersrum denken. Meine Idee ist eine Visualisierung deiner Lunge. Aber warum ist meine Lunge in der Zigarette drin? Oh mein Gott, das ist ein Bildschirm da drauf. Das ist meine Marketingidee, ich finde es genial. Das funktioniert für mich nicht. Doch, Rauchentwöhnung. Nee, aber ich glaube, das ist nämlich das Ding, der Mensch denkt nicht logisch, der denkt einfach in klaren Bildern. Das ist mir klar inzwischen. Und deswegen, wenn du die Lunge auf die Zigarette druckst oder per digitalem Faxprojektion, Hologramm, dann denkt der Mensch, ah, ich befreie die Lunge von Rauch, indem ich das aus der Zigarette rausziehe. Der Mensch ist dumm, deswegen jetzt, wir müssen auch noch über Formel 1 sprechen,
geht bald wieder los, wo ja auch
Don't Drink and Drive
ersetzt wurde, weil man gemerkt
hat, die Leute hören nur
Drink and Drive
und die ignorieren
das Don't, aber in dem Moment, in dem du das Wort
Drink und Drive zusammen
als Satz präsentierst,
Drink and Drive, ist egal, was davorsteht, never ever, you're stupid if you, das ist egal, so und deswegen heisst es jetzt, when you drink, never drive, das ist der unkoolste fucking Slogan, uncool, da kommt bei mir an, ich sollte vielleicht, um ein bisschen cooler zu werden, ein bisschen mehr trinken, mit dem Autofahren, ich sollte mehr Eishockey schauen, weniger Formel 1. Das heißt, der neue Slogan ist Never if you have the idea to ever drink something, don't ever to take a lovely sip of wine. Please, at the occasion of a drinking event, like for example Thanksgiving, make sure that there are other people that can das ist eine riesen Texttafel
und die fahren da vorbei, wie so 0,2 Sekunden
ja, aber das ist nämlich, der Mensch ist dumm
und du musst ganz simpel mit dem arbeiten, damit das funktioniert
das ist mir klar, dass der Mensch dumm ist
deswegen würde ich lieber sagen, zieh den Rauch raus
damit irgendjemand in der Zigarette befreit ist
oder so
so, wir kommen zurück zu den Oscars
das ist der Oscast, ich verstehe gar nicht, deswegen ja, sorry ganze Zeit mit dem Hydrometer anzängst. Das war kurz B-Plot. Florentin mit seinem Hydrometer. Wirklich wie so ein Mitfünfziger, Sechziger. Das ist, glaube ich, so ein richtiges Mann-Dingen, dass man irgendwann als alter Mann holt man sich so eine Wetterstation. Und ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe es. Ja, ich bin auch nicht weit davon entfernt. Ich verstehe es. Allein Messungen sind was ganz was Fass. Allein, dass ich in meiner Wohnung etwas habe, was den Suffix Station in sich trägt. Stefan, das ist eine Wetterstation. Mega gut, eine Station. Weißt du, wo ich gerade bin gedanklich? Wo ich nie dachte, dass ich da bin? Jemals in meinem Kopf Treibhäuser. Ich hätt gern Treibhaus. Was willst du treiben? Also was willst du antreiben? Tomatchen, Paprika, Paprika, Paprika, ja, Orangen, Sellerie, Karotten. Okay, und am Ende hast du einen sehr ungenießbaren Obstsalat, mit dem du nichts anstellst. Warum? Sellerie, Tomaten und Orangen zusammen sehe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gerade noch nicht. Rhabarber. Aber ja, finde ich gut. Nee, ich mag einfach diese Idee. Ich habe auch, muss ich sagen, es kommt ein bisschen daher, ich habe Hogwarts Legacy gespielt. Ich habe das Spiel Hogwarts Legacy gespielt. Und da bist du natürlich wie heisst sie, Professor
Garlic.
Wie heisst sie, Professor Squirt?
Professor Squirt.
Ja.
Die Schwimmlehrerin.
Nee, die Knollenlady,
wie heisst sie denn?
Ja, weiss ich.
Wie heisst sie denn? Die mit der Eiraune. Ja,reignisse haben die einfach wiederholt im Spiel, diese Szene. Professor Sprout. Sprout, genau, Sprout. Das ist das Tolle an Harry Potter, dass du nie lange nachdenken musst, weil die Namen sehr unkreativ sind. Ja, und im Spiel heisst sie nämlich Garlic, Miss Garlic. Ich warick, ich fand die sehr, sehr cool. Und jetzt hast du gedacht, du willst auch sowas sein, aber... So, und da diese Faszination. Du hast ja keine Magie in dir. Du bist ja jetzt, naja, sorry, aber... Was sonst, Wasser? Naja, ja, genau. Wenn du elf bist, entscheidet sich, hast du Magie in den Knochen oder Wasser? Hast du Wasser in den Füssen oder Magie in den Füssen? Ja, oder hast du schwere Knochen oder nicht? Und du hast ja mit elf nicht den Brief bekommen, sorry. Und deswegen, Daniel ist ja leider im Spamfilter hängen geblieben. Ich war trotzdem da und es war keine schöne Zeit. Ja, das stimmt. Noch schlimmer als Zauberer in der Muggelwelt haben es nämlich Leute wie ich, die einfach gesagt haben, fuck it, ich gehe in diesen Zug. Weil am Anfang der Klasse wurde immer die Anwesenheit durchgegangen und dann irgendwie hier, alle wurden durchgegangen, alle Namen und dann so, ach so, Moment mal, Sie haben sich gar nicht gemeldet. Sie da hinten. Ja, oder ich hätte mich vielleicht auch gemeldet, gesagt, ich stehe gar nicht auf der Liste. Warum stehen Sie nicht auf der Liste? Kann ich mal Ihren Brief sehen? Den habe ich zu Hause vergessen. Sie hätten ohne Brief gar nicht hier reinkommen können. Ich bin drin. Die Gargoyles am Eingangsportal hätten Sie eigentlich gar nicht durchlassen sollen. Ergo habe ich einen Brief bekommen. Nein, nein, aber wir brauchen Ihren Brief, sonst können Sie nicht am Unterricht teilnehmen. Akiobrief. Nee, muss ich noch ein bisschen besser lernen, den Spruch. Gut, dann muss ich Sie leider der Klasse verweisen bis dahin.
Nee. Tut mir leid.
Tut mir leid. Sie können
entweder zu den Gargäulen gehen oder zu den lebenden
Fröschen. Miss Birth Whistle.
Ich
Sie können mich nicht rausschmeißen. Sie halten den Unterricht
gerade auf. Sie halten den Unterricht auf. Sie bringen
uns bei, wie man Tiere
in Trinkpokale verwandelt.
Ja, wofür soll das überhaupt gut sein? Man muss trinken, Wasser ist in allen Dingen und deswegen brauchen wir Wasser in den Körper.
Miss Birthwistle, wofür soll das gut sein, Tiere in Trinkpokale zu verwandeln?
Okay, Sie verlassen jetzt den Raum oder ich verwandle sie in einen Trinkkelch. Ich verwandle sie in einen Trinkkelch und dann bestehen sie zu 90% aus Wasser, ich fülle sie ran voll mit Wasser.
Das sage ich dem Schulleiter. Gut, von mir aus. Mr. Petential Grillson. So heißt er nicht. Okay, gut. Tschüss. Und du durftest nie an irgendeiner Klasse teilnehmen, weil du nicht diesen verdammten Zettel hattest. Du hast dich einfach nur in den Zug geschmuggelt. Ja. Du Muggel, du Schmuggelmuggel, du Elinder Schmuggelmuggel. Ich, äh, ja, denke mir nur, weil man das, ich habe so eine Faszination für diese Gewächshäuser, ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Aber du musst ja, also du bist ja ein Mensch, der, sage ich mal, oft die Erwartungen enttäuscht bekommen hat. Du hast viele Phasen, du hast immer tolle Hoffnungen, du denkst, das wird richtig cool und am Ende machst du es dann doch nicht. Hier, finde ich, ist ein klares Beispiel, dass man das wirklich schon sehr stark kommen sieht. Weil du hast dich inspirieren lassen von einer magischen Welt, in der auf magische Weise magische Pflanzen wachsen. Und jetzt sagst du, das will ich auch machen. Allrauen züchten. Genau, aber merkst du nicht, wo vielleicht der Unterschied ist zwischen einem Harry Potter Videogame und der echten Welt, wo du halt am Ende Gurken züchtest. Ja, aber nach drei Sekunden kann ich eine Gurke nehmen. Nein, kannst du nicht. Du kannst nicht A drücken und die Gurke ernten, das funktioniert nicht. Y. Du hast am Ende eine winzig kleine Gurke von Schnecken zerfressen. Das nimmst du zurück. Das ist leider so. Es ist leider so.
Ja, weißt du was? Im Alter, das ist die Frage, eine spannende Frage, diese Phasen zu haben, ist eine recht kindliche Einstellung, es ist so Begeisterungsfähigkeit, Naivität. Ja, so klassische Teenager, man findet sich gerade, Punk, Emo, wo gehör ich hin?
Ja, und jetzt ist ja diese klassische Frage mit seinem inneren Kind, wie geht man mit seinem inneren Kind um. Wie würdest du, weil ich glaube, du hast irgendwann das innere Kind getötet. Du hast es genommen und das Genick gebrochen. Weil du fängst es an, was zu sagen, Stefan, sei mal vernünftig. Dann kannst du das Gewicht des Körpers nutzen und dann kannst du das relativ schnell drehen. Wie beim Schwan oder beim Huhn. Du kannst teilweise in jeder Hand zwei Schwäne halten. Wirklich, wenn du den Griff beherrschst, kannst du insgesamt vier Schwäne gleichzeitig das Genick brechen. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Du kannst, ich glaube, mindestens 80 Schwäne in der Minute töten. Ja, überhaupt kein Problem. Wenn die sich aufreihen, links und rechts von mir, und ich die jeweils paarweise gut packen kann, ist es überhaupt kein Problem.
Jetzt kann man sogar nicht sogar vier nehmen gleichzeitig.
Das ist schwer, aber das ist ein bisschen Übung. Wenn ich da so durch 200 Schwäne gehe, glaube ich, kriege ich das hin. Schwan isst man nicht, man isst Hühnchen viel, man isst Enten, man isst viele Füge. Also ich weiss nur, dass es in England das, das königliche Tier ist, the swan, und deswegen nicht gegessen werden darf.
Und das ist auf Höchststrafe und allem möglichen. Du wirst verbannt nach Irland, wenn du da ein Schwan isst. Und deswegen ist das überhaupt keine gute Idee. Aber es stimmt nicht, ich habe auch Phasen. Ich habe auch diverse Phasen, wie gesagt, ich trinke gern Tee, giesse ich mir gerne ein. Jetzt ein Wetterstationchen. Meine Hydrometer, da schaue ich gerne drauf, mit meinem Tee in der Hand, also ich würde sagen, mein Leben ist aufregend genug.
Genau, aber halt auch langsam.
Es ist auch lang, ich habe jetzt letztens, habe ich mal mir wieder eine Buttermilch geholt, die hatte ich lange nicht und die schmeckt okay, also es ist jetzt nicht so.
Hast du schon erzählt. Es schmeckt jetzt nicht, es ist jetzt nicht so ... Hast du schon erzählt. Es schmeckt jetzt nicht so, dass ...
Stell dir vor, du hörst nach so einer Geschichte, das hast du schon gesagt. Ach so.
Ach so, ja.
Du hast schon erzählt, dass du dir neulich vor zwei Wochen eine Buttermilch gekriegt hast.
Ich habe meine Buttermilch, ja stimmt. Ach so, sorry.
Ah, egal.
So, also mein, jetzt kommen wir zu den Oscars, mein absoluter Lieblingsfilm war tatsächlich The Brutalist. Habe ich nicht gesehen, kann ich nicht mitreden. Du bist fast vier Stunden im Kino, mit Pause und Trailern und so Werbung bist du bestimmt vier Stunden, das ist ein halber Arbeitstag. Wie oft gehst du zur Snackbar? Hast du nochmal nachgefüllt, nochmal an Nachos? Nee, weil ich den so gut fand, ist mir das dabei nicht aufgefallen.
Man muss sich vorstellen, ich liege auf meiner Couch,
Doomscroll durch TikTok, hab so einen irren Blick dabei,
dann gucke ich auf die Uhr und denke mir, ich war gar nicht draußen,
gucke in meine Kino-App, ich habe so ein Abo,
wo man einfach spontan ins Kino gehen kann
und kannst einfach zack auf den Platz drücken, muss nichts zahlen, zahlst einmal im Jahr einen Betrag und kannst so viele Filme sehen, wie du willst. Dann merke ich, ah, gleich laufen Filmen bei mir um die Ecke im Kino, ich laufe da hin und bin noch mit diesem TikTok-Doom-Scrolling-Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, sitze ich da im Sessel und ich merke dann wirklich tatsächlich, dass ich da ein Problem habe inzwischen mit so langen Laufzeiten. Das ist wirklich problematisch, man sollte vielleicht auch einfach aufhören mit dem Scheiss. Aber bei The Brutalist vier Stunden lang hatte für mich keine Länge. Habe ich absolut geliebt, ich fand die Musik fantastisch, Adrian Brody spielt das toll, hat auch gestern zu Recht gewonnen. Ja. Die Musik hat auch zu Recht Oscar gewonnen, aber sagt noch weiterhin stärkend ja. Brody. Und nee, absolut toll, hat großen Spaß gemacht, tolles Thema, super schick. Und ja, deswegen kann ich nur empfehlen. Aber vier Stunden würdest du sagen, dass du mit anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit, dann wenn du so im Kino sagst, so können wir, können wir, können wir beschleunigen oder wollt ihr alle, können wir, gibt es ein Veto? Glaubst du, das wird irgendwann auch in Kinos angeboten? Weil Netflix hat das bereits eingeführt, erhöhte Geschwindigkeit, doppelte Geschwindigkeit, achtfache, zwölf, sechzehnfache Geschwindigkeit. Wird das auch in Kinos eingeführt, dass man sagt, okay, wir machen alle fünf Vorstellungen, machen wir eine Vorstellung, wo der Film in anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit gezeigt wird. Ja, wird ein bisschen problematisch, weil das natürlich dann Filme in Deutsch synchronisiert, die steht ja irgendwann so O, M, U, also original mit Untersiedeln und dann gibt es das Deutsch in zweifacher Geschwindigkeit, O, M, U in zweifacher Geschwindigkeit und so viele Säle gibt es schlicht nicht. Du hast ganz viele Sachen Beispiel, wenn du bei einigen Fastfood-Restaurants, gibt es das mittlerweile, dass du nicht mehr das Getränk bestellst, sondern du kriegst da nur noch einen Becher und hast selber so einen Automaten, wo es tatsächlich nach amerikanischem Vorbild einfach unfassbar viele Permutationen gibt, wo du sagst, du hast Cola Light mit Vanille und Cherry, Root Beer mit Vanille und Cherry und Himbeer und Light. Da kriegst du. Du willst Cherry in Light, aber Himbeer nicht in Light und du willst Peach noch dazu mit Root Beer. Du kriegst Peach Fanta in Deutschland. Du kriegst da nicht nur Vanilla Coke, sondern die haben auch Vanilla Cherry Coke. Das ist so krass. Die haben auch Cherry Coke. So krass. Und Vanilla Cherry Coke habe ich überlegt, schon mal mit Cherry Coke zu mischen. Dann hast du ein Dreiviertel, ein Einviertel-Dreiviertel-System. Also du mischt Cherry Coke mit Vanilla Coke mit Cherry und Vanilla Coke. Ja, das musst du nicht machen, weil dann hast du am Ende Cherry Vanilla Coke. Okay, aber so ist es mit Filmen auch irgendwann, dass du sagst, ich will OMU mit 1,2-facher Geschwindigkeit von dem Regisseur mit dem und dann wird einfach die KI generiert den Film komplett einmal und dann schaust du den da. Ich bin nur froh, wenn mehr Entscheidungen abgenommen werden. Wenn es schon Vanilla, Cherry, Coke gibt, gehe ich davon aus, das ist das optimale Mischverhältnis. Vielleicht haben die nicht eins zu eins, vielleicht haben die etwas Besseres sich überlegt. They are the geniuses. Andere Idee im Kino, wenn alle merken, also es gibt ja manchmal bei Videospielen das Prinzip, wenn alle die mitmachen auf weiter klicken, geht's weiter. Alle im Kino haben an seinem Sitz so einen Button, das ist der Boring Button, der BB Boring Button. Und wenn man dann drückt,
also ich mag den Film nicht so gern, und dann klicke ich
so heimlich auf
zweifache Geschwindigkeit. Und wenn das
eine genug grosse Anzahl
im Kino auch drückt, wird der Film
ab dem Moment in zweifacher Geschwindigkeit. Und dann kann man
aber nochmal drücken, um es
in vierfache Geschwindigkeit zu bringen. Und dann
einfach irgendwann gegen Ende drückt man. Und dann kann man es auch
Skipp zur nächsten Sexszene, kannst du so draufklicken. Ist das sehr laut, wenn man auf den Knopf drückt? Ja. Und du hast so einen Scheinwerfer von oben, der so auf dich drauf zeigt. Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Oder kommt so ein Moderation, Steven Gersche kommt dann rein und sagt, wir halten können das Filme an, Sie haben gesagt, Sie wollen... Ich finde, das Pacing ist nicht gut und ich habe gehört, Timothy Chalamet spielt mit in der zweiten Hälfte und den ich gerne sehen. Und bis dahin ist mir eigentlich völlig egal, was passiert. New Ick Unlocked, New Ick, wenn jemand sagt, das Pacing eines Films war nicht. Ja, absolut. Neuer, anderer Ick, wenn jemand sagt, der Film, und das höre ich sehr oft, war sehr schön fotografiert. Uff. Der Film war schön fotografiert. Die mise en scene.
Oder auch dieses Klassische, der Film ist eine halbe Stunde zu lang. Das ist auch so ein klassischer Satz. Ich finde, es gibt ja so, wenn du so Business-BWL-krasser Typ bist, dann gibt es ja so Tabellen von Wörtern, wo du sagst, sag nicht das, sag das, sag nicht gut, sag irgendwie rentabel oder exzellent, brillant oder irgendwie sowas. Ich finde, sowas sollte es auch geben, aber in die andere Richtung.
Sag anstatt, der Film hat ein schlechtes Pacing, sag, der Film ist langweilig. Also einfach, sag einfach, was du fühlst und dann kommen wir und statt der Film ist eine halbe Stunde zu lang, sag, der Film ist langweilig. So, ich habe mich gelangweilt. Für das, was er sein sollte. Vollkommen in Ordnung. Einfach war nicht meins. Genau, wir müssen wieder so ein bisschen zurückstufen. Die Zuschauer sind zu smart geworden. Nee, nicht smart. Die benutzen Worte wie Franchise und Intellectual Property. Und die wissen viel zu viel, die müssen wieder so ein bisschen ... Ich glaube, das ist schlecht für den Zuschauer, wenn man zu viel weiß über diese Branche, über das Business. Aber auch ein anderer, ich, neulich war ich im Restaurant und dann kam der Kellner bei jedem Gang an, das war so ein Menü-Restaurant und dann bei jedem Gang kam er an, hat den Teller bei uns auf den Tisch gestellt und gesagt, viel Spaß damit. Uff. So und jetzt viel Spaß damit. Und ich dachte jedes Mal, ich will es lieber nicht mehr essen jetzt. Nee, Spaß kannst du beim Essen nicht mehr wünschen. Aber kennst du das beim, du trinkst jetzt kein Alkohol, aber wenn man Wein bekommt am Tisch und dann hast du so einen Sommelier, der einem so einen Wein erklärt, dann sagt der manchmal sowas wie, der ist halt was Besonderes. Der kommt rein und sagt Hallo und der macht richtig Spaß. Der kommt rein, der ist kräftig, ein bisschen samzig im Abgang, wenig Frucht, ein bisschen mehr Säure, aber ganz ausgewogen, ein bisschen Eiche, der macht richtig Spaß. Fick dich. Wenn das jemand sagt, der Wein macht Spaß oder hier viel Spaß beim Essen, sag, guten Appetit oder guten, guten, Mahlzeit, sowas, das geht. Nee, das funktioniert nicht. Also ich werde auch völlig überfordert, wenn ich da irgendwas aussuchen müsste. Ich kenne es ja von diesen Automaten mit den ganz vielen Optionen. Am Ende eine absolute Abscheulichkeit habe ich da zusammengestellt. Ich habe da Melo Light mit Vanilla Float, Root Beer und am Ende kommt da einfach wirklich so eine Galeertartige Masse, auch gar nicht so in so einem Strahl, sondern einfach nur so in einem Blö, dann wird es einfach rausgebrochen aus dem Automaten. Ja, weil du Melo mit Chardonnay, weil du dachtest, du willst einen modernen Mezzomix erschaffen. Nee, nee, nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Nee, nee, nee. Das funktioniert nicht, aber deswegen, je weniger Auswahlmöglichkeiten ich habe, desto besser. Ja, sehe ich ganz genau so. Was war dein Lieblingsfilm, der diesjährigen Oscar-Season? Ich liebe! Ja, also ich also ich, also der hat so viel Spaß gemacht, der Film, ich liebe ja, hab ich wirklich geliebt. Der Herr der Ringe, also ich liebe den ja, der hat so viel und das Pacing ist perfekt, ich weiss nicht, ob der jetzt bei den Oscars eine Rolle gespielt hat, aber den schaue ich immer wieder gerne an, auch den Hobbit. 2000 um den Dreh. Ja, wow, 25 Jahre, Mensch, die Zeit verfliegt. Aber nee, ich bin, ich kann das auch nicht aussuchen. Ich will nicht ins Kino, mich nerven die Leute, ich habe einfach keinen Bock mehr darauf. Ich habe sogar den Anime-Rohan-Film nicht gesehen, obwohl ich eher Ringe-Fan bin, weil ich einfach keinen Bock habe auf Leute, die nerven und laber, laber, laber, habe ich einfach keinen Bock mehr. Ja, das hat mich auch so aufgeregt. Bei The Brutalist war neben mir ein Mann, der war auch alleine da und der war schon ein bisschen älter und der war so sehr grumpy eh schon, als ich so reingekommen bin. Ich habe mich da hingesetzt und gesagt, hallo, und er hat nur komisch geguckt. Und dann hatte er jedes Mal, wenn jemand aufgestanden ist, weil er oder sie aufs Klo musste, was bei einem dreieinhalb Stunden Film schon mal einfach passieren kann, immer gesagt, setz dich hin, du Motherfucker. Sit down, please, Motherfucker. Geschrien, geschrien. Was? Ja, geschrien. Und das war so interessant für mich, dass er das für eine ... Auf Englisch? Was? Ja. Der Film wurde auf Englisch gezeigt. Er war deutsch, offensichtlich. Ach so, der passt sich dann auch an, der Sprache des Films. Er passt sich der O an. Okay, das ist okay, OV. Also der gesagt, ich bin jetzt auch OV. Ich bin heute auch die Originalversion. Wobei, wenn er OV sprechen will, wäre das ja deutsch. Richtig, ja, okay, stimmt. Er war voiced. Fantastisch. Nee, ich fand das ganz schlimm. Also, ganz furchtbar natürlich, aber als Figur sehr interessant. Und aber wenn die Leute zurückgekommen sind, gab es dann auch einen Kommentar? Oder einfach nur... Doch, also ihm hat es nicht gepasst, Köpfe vor der Leinwand zu sehen. Ah ja, verstehe. Also auch wenn die zurückkam, hat er gesagt, sit down, motherfucker, sit down. Aber es war jetzt nicht irgendwie krank oder Tourette oder sowas, sondern es war schon, ähm, einfach Wut. Einfach Wut auf den, auf die Sicht, Einschränkung auf der Leinwand. Einerseits natürlich, ich kritisiere die Störung, aber ich mag diese Intensität. Wenn der so reagiert, auch hätte, wenn Leute reden oder so, so be quiet, motherfucker, so, dann fände ich es geil. Dann, wenn wirklich jemand sagt, so, ey, es gibt hier Regeln, ich setze das hier durch, ich finde das gut. Ich glaube, aus der Person kann man was machen. Hast du die Handynummer? Ich glaube, für dich... Danach wollte ich jetzt nicht zu dem Winkern und sagen, grosser Fan ihres Werks. Können wir ein Foto machen, kann ich die Nummer haben? Sind Sie bei Instagram oder haben Sie... Solche Leute brauche ich in der GO. Solche Leute brauche ich, die zurechtweisen in die Gesellschaftsordner, die wirklich auch Leute von den Rolltreppen wegschmeissen, die Leute aus dem Ruhebereich. Genau, das ist eine faschistische Bewegung, eine pseudofaschistische Bewegung. Ordnungsfaschismus. Ja, in gewisser Weise.
Und es muss wieder Ordnung einkehren,
und dafür brauche ich solche Leute, die wirklich auch durchgreifen.
Ich finde es so spannend, weil er ja eine ganz klare,
und deswegen, ich habe den Film gut in Erinnerung,
vielleicht habe ich aber gar nicht so viel mitbekommen,
weil ich die ganze Zeit darüber nachgedacht habe,
wie er die Sinne priorisiert in seinem Kopf.
Weil er priorisiert Sehen deutlich über Hören. Ja, er ist laut, weil er nicht gut sehen kann. Er kann nicht sehen und findet diese Störung sehr, sehr schlimm. Und brachial schreit er durch die Kinosaal. Und das ist für ihn offensichtlich keine grosse Störung gewesen. Für mich ist es viel grössere Störung. Ja, wie so ein Medium sagt. Beim dritten Mal gesagt, pscht, habe ich gesagt. Okay. Nicht darauf reagiert. Gar keine Reaktion. Er war nicht mehr wahr. Wahrscheinlich, was du stattdessen hättest machen sollen, wäre pscht, motherfucker. So, dass du mit ihm seine Sprache redest, so dass das bei ihm wirklich auch ankommt. Weil sonst weiss er gar nicht, willst du dir jetzt noch was sagen? Ja. Also kommt da noch was? Du meinst, es ist ein Over, wie bei Walkie Talkies. Das ist wie Over, ja. Der denkt, okay, du schreibst noch. Ich schreib noch. Stefan schreibt. Und du weisst gar nicht, wann kommt die Nachricht eigentlich. Genau, wenn man nicht Amen sagt. Wir haben noch ganz viele Gebete offen. Ein alter Tweet von Stefan. Ein alter Tweet war, wenn du beim Gebet nicht Amen sagst, sprichst du Gott bis, wenn du bei deinem letzten Gebet nicht Amen gesagt hast, sprichst du Gott bis jetzt auf die Mailbox.
Genau. Das war glaube ich. Ein unvergessener Tweet von Stefan Tietze.
Ich finde ihn recht vergessen.
Ach so, ich habe ihn nicht vergessen.
Ich habe ihn schon vergessen.
Ich würde ihn nicht vergessen. Teilweise wache ich nachts noch mal auf, lachend über deine alten Tweets und denke mir, Mensch, der Junge.
Ja, aber... Ich finde den recht vergessen. Ach so, ich habe ihn nicht vergessen. Ich habe ihn schon vergessen. Ich würde ihn nicht vergessen. Teilweise wache ich nachts noch mal auf, lachend über deine alten Tweets und denke mir, Mensch, der Junge.
Ja, aber ich vermisse wirklich ein Wortmedium, bin ich ehrlich.
Buch?
Nee, ich meine ein Wort Social Medium.
Stimmt, ja, es fehlt ein bisschen.
Threads hat für mich nicht geschaffen. So dieses neue Blue Sky Tentatonix, Mastodon.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, jetzt haben sich irgendwie alle aufgeteilt zwischen Mastodon und Blue Sky und dann haben manche Threads als die neue Place to be, weiss nicht, Plattform wahrgenommen und jetzt ist es irgendwie so, alle haben sich so aufgeteilt, aber es ist nicht mehr dieses alte Gefühl, dieses alte, wir reden miteinander. Was waren das für Zeiten, für naive Zeiten, wo wir da alle gemeinsam bei Twitter waren und so Sterne gegeben haben? Wir müssen den grossen Twitter-Abgesang machen. Ich habe es gesagt, wir müssen noch mal wirklich was, noch mal eine Fahne in den Boden rammen und einfach sagen, das war die Zeit bis hier und nicht weiter, das war schön. Es ist wie wenn man so als Gruppe irgendwie in so ein Restaurant geht und dann gibt es so kleine Tische und alle teilen sich so auf. Und man denkt sich, ich sitze nicht am Kohlentisch, ich sitze nicht bei Pascal, ich sitze nicht bei Froni.
Bei wem?
Ich sitze nicht bei Froni, bei Pascal, bei Jeannette,
ich sitze nicht bei Boris.
Ich sitze hier bei Jochen, bei Uwe und bei Clara.
Ja.
Und dann denkst du, der ist eigentlich der Abend schon gelaufen.
Lamer Tisch.
Der Abend ist eigentlich schon gelaufen,
Schullandheim, wenn du nicht im richtigen Zimmer bist,
hast du komplett verloren.
Es kommt dann doch irgendwie auch auf die Aufteilung an.
Ich war mal bei einem wichtigen Business-Dinner abends. Wenn du nicht im richtigen Zimmer bist, hast du komplett verloren. Es kommt dann doch irgendwie auch auf die Aufteilung an.
Ich war mal bei einem wichtigen Business-Dinner abends, war ich sehr traurig danach, weil ich falsch gesessen habe. Ich habe zwischen zwei Lame Ducks gesessen, die haben ... Die eigentlich schon abgewählt waren, aber nur wo vor man noch da war. Du hast ja dann so Side-Gespräche eingespannt und du hörst die ganze Zeit am anderen Ende des Tisches. Ja, genau so machen wir es und du hörst auf Wortfetzen so wichtig Dinge, die dich betreffen und du bist in so einem weirden Gespräch. Genau, du bist in einem Gespräch gefangen und hörst eigentlich dem besseren Gespräch zu, gar nicht deinem eigenen, aber du bist einfach gefangen in dem und willst immer so, ja, ne, das ist ganz furchtbar, ganz schlimm. Und bei einem anderen Gespräch hat mir mal jemand gesagt, dass das war eine Schauspielerin bei so einem Kennenlernen, also vor dem Drehstart, so einem Kennenlernen-Abend, so wo man gemeinsam in der Stadt zusammenkommt, dann wird nächsten Tag gedreht.
Und Rechtsverkehr initiiert.
Und sie hat dann mir zu verstehen gegeben, dass sie bei mir falsch sitzt, weil sie mitbekommen hat, dass die Regisseure an einem anderen Tisch sitzen. Und das fand ich auf eine Art irgendwie auch sau stark, hat dann gesagt, oh, dann bin ich hier falsch.
Und ist dann tatsächlich einfach zu den Quote-unquote wichtigeren Menschen. Das finde ich schon cool. Ich meine, man ist nicht immer der Gewinner in solchen Geschichten. Nee, aber ich muss auch sagen, sie hat das gut gemacht. Es ist wichtig, dass man auch einsieht, ich bin der Verlierer hier gerade, ich bin das schwarze Loch, ich sauge hier gerade die Laune weg. Und sich dann auch zu entfernen und zu sagen, ich setze mich mal woanders hin oder irgendwie so, das ist natürlich schon wichtig. Und mir gefällt auch dieses, mir geht es heute Abend um Business. Mir geht es nicht um Freizeit und Leute kennenlernen und so, fuck you, du interessest mich nicht, ich gehe jetzt von wichtigen Leuten da hinten hin. Auf eine Art ist das sehr ehrlich. Ja. Also es widerspricht gegen so ein paar Verhaltenskodexe, aber es ist schon gut. Es erspart einem Sinnlosen.
Ich würde das gerne können, ey, ich würde das gerne können, wirklich sowas direkt ansprechen und zu sagen, hey, ich glaube, wir kommen heute nicht zusammen, ich würde mich gerne woanders hinsetzen oder ich gehe. Ich würde mich einfach unterm Tisch zusammenkauern und ein Buch lesen und dann bin ich einfach raus für heute Abend, wenn das okay ist. Ich würde mir vielleicht noch zwei Flammkuchen bestellen, die direkt vor Ort einpacken lassen und die dann unterm Tisch verzehren. Also gar nichts gegen dich jetzt, ich glaube einfach nur, du merkst es auch, es kommt nicht so richtig voran, es hebt nicht so richtig ab. es wie so ein frühes Wrights Brothers Flugzeug, das einfach nicht abhebt und man sich fragt, wo soll der Auftrieb herkommen. Es kann auch physikalisch nicht klappen, also das wird gezogen von zwei Eseln, die Flügel sind krumm und nach oben gekippt aus irgendeinem Grund. Wir sind, glaube ich, einfach technologisch noch nicht so weit. Auch eine spannende gesellschaftliche Geflogenheit finde ich, Leute zum Essen einladen oder zu etwas einladen. Ich bin da sehr schlecht drin, weil ich mache es immer am Anfang, weil ich das nicht für mich behalten kann, diese Euphorie. Ich mache das gern. Und dann sage ich das, aber dann ist so viel Druck auf dem anderen. Also angenommen, man geht irgendwie essen, dann wäre, ich finde, das Beste wäre eigentlich, jeder isst, was er oder sie will. Einfach ohne Vorbehalte. Und dann am Ende sagt jemand, ah, du bist eingeladen übrigens. Auf die Rechnung. Das wäre, glaube ich, die nette Art, das zu machen. Weil wenn ich jetzt sage, ich würde dich gerne heute Abend einladen. Ach so, ich nehme den kleinen Pinocchio-Becher und einen Salat. Genau. Ja. Weil wenn ich jetzt sage, ich würde dich gerne heute Abend einladen, dann ist so ... Ich nehme den kleinen Pinocchio-Becher und einen Salat. Genau. Ja, oder? Also man denkt die ganze Zeit so, kann ich jetzt das teurere nehmen? Ich werde gerne das teurere. Von daher, einladen muss man können. Boah, das ist schwierig. Das ist schwierig. Das ist wirklich schwierig. Vor allem, ich denke dann so, ja, okay, ich nehme jetzt die super teure Teriyaki-Ente,
aber ich würde dann auch selber die Hälfte zahlen oder nicht und so und dann verhandelt man.
Dann verhandelt man, ein bisschen Basar.
Wie viel habe ich denn? Wie viel habe ich?
Das ist eigentlich das Beste, wenn du direkt klare Zahlen setzt.
Genauso wie damals am Süssigkeiten Auslag, am Kiosk, wenn es heißt, okay, ich habe 1,50 Euro, alles klar.
So, ich nehme was, ich habe jetzt noch
1,40 Euro, zwei Schlümpfe, 1,30 Euro
und du weißt genau, wo du bist
und nicht, ich lade dich ein, mit wie viel,
wie viel habe ich so Gutscheine,
klare Ansage, so viel
Betrag. Weil, ich erinnere
mich noch, es ist so ein Papa erzählt
von früher, die Inflation ist
so schlimm, Talk, aber
ich erinnere mich noch damals, dass man gesagt hat, ich hätte gerne eine gemischte Tüte für zwei Euro. Und der Kiosk-Besitzer hat die grosse Tüte rausgeholt. Okay. Zum Safe, mach die auf, hol die grosse Tüte raus. Hol die grosse Tüte raus, legt sie unter so ein Ding, macht den Hebel auf.
Und da kamen die
Schlümpfe rein. Ja, und es waren eine Menge
fucking Schlümpfe. Bei zwei Euro hat es
nicht aufgehört. Ja, es hat richtig
aufgehört. Du dachtest dir, selbst wenn
ich alles einmal nehme, bin ich noch nicht am Limit.
Was ich mir noch nicht wieder geholt habe,
weil es mich an meine Kindheit erinnert, und ich habe es
ewig nicht im Supermarkt gesehen,
und ich habe es geholt, und es hat mich an meine Kindheit erinnert und ich habe es ewig nicht im Supermarkt gesehen und ich habe es geholt und es hat mich an meine Kindheit erinnert, Violas, Haribo, Violas. Violas? Sind das diese Weingummis? Nein. Oder was ist das? Violas sind diese violetten Distill Dragees, in der Mitte ist es Lakritz und außen ist es so eine Anis-artige. Also wenn das dein Kindheitssnack war, das ist ja schon wirklich beeindruckend. Was magst du am liebsten? Lakritz mit Anis. Äh, okay. Ich mag am liebsten Wirsing, Blumenkohl und Lakritz mit Anis. Am liebsten mag ich eine Furgra mit Brioche und einer kleinen Quitten-Konfib und dazu, das nachtisch gerne, Violas, das sind Lakritz mit Anis. Ach, Alter, was warst du für ein Kind, einfach wie so dieses abgehobene Kind. Violas, die hatten wir bei uns. Aber glaube ich, habe ich noch nie genossen. Die schmeckt ein bisschen nach Seife. Es ist auch nicht, irgendwas habe ich jetzt noch vergessen, Zucker-Sirup.
Ja, ja, und dann so diese Käfer, die Glasur, ne?
Da gibt es dann so auch diese Glasur außenrum aus Käfern und so, damit das alles so zusammen dragiert ist.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ultra lecker.
Das schmeckt wirklich wie, als würdest du ein Stück Seife beißen.
Wenn Dinge so schmecken könnten, wie sie riechen, das wäre doch fantastisch, oder, wenn so eine Seife wirklich genauso schmecken würde, wie sie riecht. Kann man da nicht mal daran arbeiten, dass wir da einheitlich europaweit sagen, Dinge schmecken auch so, wie sie riechen, Punkt. Dinge müssen riechen, wie sie schmecken, Dinge müssen schmecken, wie sie riechen. Dinge müssen riechen, wie sie schmecken und schmecken, wie sie riechen, ansonsten kommen sie nicht durch den Zoll. Ende. So, zack, Ende Gelände. Ja, meine Ansage. Einfach sagen, so Freunde, jetzt pass mal auf. Ja, Herr Brinkmeier, Ihre Redezeit ist vorbei. Nee, meine Redezeit hat gerade erst angefangen. Dinge müssen aussehen, wie sie riechen. Achten Sie auf die Uhr. Dinge müssen schmecken, wie sie aussehen. Und sie müssen riechen, wie sie aussehen. Und sie müssen gelb sein. Gelb, alles gelb. Sie müssen sich anfühlen, wie sie schmecken. Und sie müssen schmecken, wie sie riechen. Und alles muss einheitlich sein. Kommt mir nicht mit diesem Quatsch da, mit diesem Larifari da. Ich habe letztens auch wieder einen kleinen Kindheitsschock bekommen aus der Vergangenheit, und zwar Esspapier. Das gute alte Esspapier, was so eine ganz merkwürdige Nischenexistenz hat, als selbst Kinder mögen das nicht wirklich, glaube ich, das ist eher so, ah, das ist super billig, du kriegst für 50 Cent, kriegst du so die ganze Packung mit 10 Scheiben, es ist einfach, du nimmst es in den Mund, es ist einfach straight am Gaumen, einfach direkt, wie ich auftringe, einfach Wrights Brothers, zack, nach oben am Gaumen, ist dafür die gesamte Pubertät komplett, du kannst nie wieder normal reden. Immer noch ein bisschen Esspapier am Gaumen. Immer noch Esspapier, wenn ihr mal nachguckt mit eurer Mundkamera, findet ihr immer noch Relikte von Esspapier da oben. Ja, Geschmack, schmeckt es überhaupt nach irgendwas? Jeder von uns kennt doch irgendwie sowas, was diese von den Sims, die Sims, die haben doch oben drüber diese Kristalle, der anzeigt, wen du spielst oder so. Das würde ich gerne essen. Ja, das ist gut. Menschen haben doch Dinge, die sie gerne, die sind nicht zum Essen da, das kennt doch jeder, du kennst doch Dinge, die sind nicht zum Essen da, aber du würdest da schon gerne mal reinbeißen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Zum Beispiel so manche Kieselsteine, finde ich, die so eine ganz glatte Oberfläche haben und so ein bisschen rau sind, würde ich gerne reinbeissen.
Auch so Kakteen, so Sukkulenten, so diese grüne, so saftig.
Denkst du, ist das eher wie so ein Keks oder ein Kuchen oder so mit diesem Aloe Vera, was dann so eine Füllung, so ein saftiger.
Ja, wie so ein Erfrischungsstäbchen in der Mitte kann das so geil sein.
Das wäre so geil, aber man darf das verboten.
Und hast du bei Papier schon mal jemals gedacht, da würde ich gerne reinbeißen? Eher weniger. Eben, und das ist genau der Grund. Papier ist einfach eine unsexy, also diese so kleine Dragees oder sowas, klar, wie man sich die ins Maul steckt. Aber Papier ja nicht. So ein Golfball oder so. Ja, so ein Golfball-Ausler-Kritier, ich denke mir, unfassbar dünn, ich denke mir immer so, aus Esspapier müsste man eigentlich noch was weitermachen. Ich finde, Esspapier ist eine gute Grundlage, ich bin ja riesen Waffelfan, dass man da noch mal sagt, keine Ahnung, Esspapier, jetzt mal einfach so in die Tüte gesprochen, so Esspapier mit hauchdünnem Marmelade dazwischen, so zwei Scheiben Esspapier mit ein bisschen Marmelade dazwischen, Aprikosemarmelade, Konfitüre, ja, Pfefferminzkonfitüre, kann man da nicht was machen, so eine Art Lasagne aus Esspapier oder so. Irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, ich esse hier einfach eine Backzutat, ohne dass daraus was gemacht wird. Oh, du hast mich erinnert an etwas, was existiert, was ich liebe, aber komplett vergessen habe. Weiner. Und ich meine, das hatten wir zu guter Arbeitszeiten, damals bei, im Netto ab und zu. Das sind so Schnitten, einfach mit einem dickeren Esspapier und dazwischen ist, ähm, was? Ist so was Fruchtiges dazwischen gewesen? Boah, bitte findet das für uns. Ich erinnere mich gar nicht. Bitte findet das für mich. Aber fest oder flüssig?
Dazwischen ist so ein bisschen flüssiger, jetzt nicht flüssig, aber es ist so gummiartig, so Kirsche, ich habe so rote Früchte-Assoziationen und außen war das so weisses, ein bisschen dickeres Esspapier. Und die kam jetzt in der Verpackung und dann sind die so leicht schon so durchgeschnitten, dann kann man sich die abmachen, dann hast du wie so eine Schnitte.
Ich habhe genau, dass du das denkst. Aber es gibt eine Sorte, die haben mich aus dem Leben gefickt. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so Astrosport-Fruchtriegel mit richtig viel Samen drin oder was. Was? Halt irgendwie so Zeug. Das klingt wie so ein Star-Trek-Hobby. Ich mache jetzt drei Minuten Astrosport und dann komme ich wieder aufs Sonnendeck. Aber manche Dinge werden ja als gesund vermarktet, wo man sich denkt, die sind nicht gesund, ich fresse die einfach in mich rein, wie blöde. Und dazu gehören ja wahrscheinlich auch diese Fruchtregeln. Ja, ja. Wo einfach so 60 Bananen. Die haben auch diese ökologische Verpackung, diese, wie heissen diese, so Reformhaus-artige Verpackung. Genau, Astrosport, und dann denkst du, ach, das klingt aber irgendwie gesund, aber es sind einfach 60.000 Kalorien pro Riegel, es sind einfach 400 Bananen gepresst in einen Kubikzentimeter. Da hab ich Bock drauf gerade. Aber ich check's nicht! Wieso nicht? Ich will's, vor allem zu guter Arbeitszeit, da hab ich glaube ich alles gefressen. Naja, wir hatten erst alles gefressen und dann haben wir nichts mehr gefressen. Dann haben wir unsere Drinks gehabt, unsere Astronautendrinks. Oh ja. Haben wir abgenommen. Habt ihr das von mir geheim gehalten? Weil das klang jetzt so als, wir haben alle zusammen das gegessen. Es gab Süssigkeiten-Schubladen, von denen du nichts wusstest. Weil wenn du davon gewusst hättest, wäre alles weg gewesen. Es gab Schränke, es gab Schubladen, es gab geheime Truhen. Das ist genauso wie bei Rocket Beans. Bei Rocket Beans gibt es auch mal so Schalen, wo so ein bisschen Süßigkeiten ausliegen. Und es gibt manche Mitarbeiter, die wissen, wo die Süßigkeiten gelagert werden. Und die werden ganz strategisch punktuell ausgesucht, wer das weiss, damit man das nachfüllen kann. Ich bin noch nicht in diesem Club und ich versuche mich immer reinzusnicken, aber die wissen ganz genau, da ist einfach der Heuschreckenschwarm, sobald ich weiß, wo das Zeug ist, ist alles hinüber, vor allem ich würde immer mal so ein bisschen was rausnehmen, so dass so vorne die Fassade bleibt, vorne denkt man, ach da sind ja noch ganz viele Minikitka da, aber dahinter ist alles leergefressen, wie so eine Ratte, wie so ein Schimmelpilz,
der hinten alles vernichtet, wo alles weg ist.
Wie ist es denn weitergegangen mit den Fürst-Pückler-Schnitten deiner Kollegin? Hast du die geklaut oder nicht?
Ja, die habe ich alle gegessen.
Die hast du alle gegessen?
Die habe ich alle gegessen.
Und hast du den Post-it noch so
wie als demütigendes Zeichen
noch so übergelassen und reingelegt?
Bei mir ist es oft so,
ich bin in so einer Verantwortungskaskade.
Wenn ich einmal was klaue,
Das ist ein Wettbewerb. Wie als demütigendes Zeichen noch so übergelassen und reingelegt? Bei mir ist es oft so, ich bin in so einer Verantwortungskaskade. Wenn ich einmal was klaue, dann denke ich, ah ja, okay, jetzt kann ich auch weitermachen. Weil ob ich jetzt von den vier, ob sie jetzt nur drei findet oder zwei, ist kein so riesengroßer Unterschied mehr. Also esse ich dann noch eins, haben sie noch zwei fürs Pücklerschnitten übrig. Dann denke ich mir, zwei ist schon echt wenig, die wird merken, dass jemand von ihren Süßigkeiten gegessen hat. Na dann kann ich ja auch noch eine essen, weil jetzt weiss sie ja schon, dass es ein Verbrechen gab. Außerdem, wenn du noch eine isst, sieht es aus, als gäbe es mehr Täter. Genau. Weil niemand ist ja so dreist und ist die. Und ist einfach drei Stück von ursprünglich mal fünf. Und dann ist noch eine Schnitte übrig, dann denke ich mir, naja, eine Schnitte zu finden ist super frustrierend, weil du weißt,
okay, irgendjemand hat alle gegessen bis auf eine,
was super respektlos ist, also das sieht ihr auch noch.
Ich wünsche mir
eine Serie, so wie
genau in dieser True Detective
ersten Staffel
Funktionalität. Okay, True Detective, okay.
Ja, so mega ernst,
super dark, super mystery, richtig dark inszeniert, so heavy und so ein Ermittler mit so einem Drogen- und Alkoholproblem. Aber es geht darum, wer hat die für Pücklerschnitten aus dem Büro Kühlschrank geklaut. Finde ich super. Also so maximal ernst das Verfolgen. Und dann auch so existenzielle Krisen und dann der Detective steigert sich zu sehr rein, die Frau beschwert sich, du bist gar nicht für die Kinder da und sagt, ich muss den Fall lösen. Der Fall überall, wo ich hinsehe, sehe ich nur Erbberg. Er betrügt auch seine Frau, die Frau, die dann die beiden einlädt, die beiden, ich habe den neuen Partner, würde ich gerne mal kennenlernen, ich lade ihm dann zum Essen ein. Nee, ich will nicht, doch, du lätst ihn jetzt zum Essen ein. So widerwillig wird dann der Partner zum Essen eingeladen.
Ich finde, Fürst Pückler ist ein mega Thema für so eine Serie, weil du hast ja immer dieses Schoko, Erdbeer, Vanille und wahrscheinlich waren es drei Täter und du findest am Tatort findest du Schoko und Vanille. Moment mal, wo ist Erdbeer? Genau, du hast Kot, Blut und Sperma. Du hast eigentlich genau die Herrenfürstpücklerschnitte quasi für Erwachsene und kannst dann da genau rekonstruieren. Und es sind irgendwie immer drei. Und aus irgendeinem Grund hat der Täter immer so drei Elemente. Und wenn eins fehlt, dann muss man auch gucken. Ich hatte tatsächlich die Überlegung, wir haben ja bei Rocket Beans im Namen des Chats gemacht, unsere Gerichtsshow, wo der Chat die Geschworenen sind. Und da geht es auch immer um Mord. Ich habe da, glaube ich, ein kleines Video damals hingeschickt, um euch zu helfen. Du warst Mr. Weasel. Ich war irgendeine Figur, die gar keine Rolle gespielt hat. Aber jetzt aus Spaß, googelt mal Stefan Tietze. Googelt mal meinen Namen und dann steht da bekannt aus Doppelpunkt im Namen des Chats. Und es ist so stark. Du warst eine tragende Rolle, du warst Mr. Wiesner. Ich erinnere mich ein bisschen darüber. Tolle Produktion, ganz toll, vielen Dank, wow, Applaus, Applaus, Applaus. Ich sehe mich da jetzt nicht so sehr drin. Also es ist nicht irgendwie eine große Selbstmeldung für mich gewesen. Du wirst auch immer noch angesprochen, sag mal, hey, jetzt muss ich doch mal fragen, wie war das denn damals bei Im des Chats, also wie war das, wie war die Dreharbeiten, oder was habt ihr da gemacht? Ich weiß, die haben zwei Minuten ein Video eingeschickt. Deshalb die Katjana und du habt in Köln in einem Park selbstständig ein Video gedreht, weil eine Verbindung zu einem anderen Influencer namens Mr. Wiesel bestehen sollte. Während des Prozesses hat es überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt, aber... Hätte. Es hätte keine Rolle spielen können, du wärst ein wichtiger Hinweis gewesen, aber da habe ich auch überlegt... Trotzdem, Google denkt, das ist da raus, kennt man mich. Und da habe ich auch überlegt, wie geil wäre eigentlich da ein kompletter Fall über, wer hat in der WG den Joghurt aus dem Kühlschrank gegessen. Aber damit die Fallhöhe ist, brauchst du natürlich ein paar normale Fälle, damit du dann so eine erste April-Folge machst, und wir haben noch nicht genug normale Fälle, aber ist auch so viel Aufwand, dass es es wahrscheinlich nie wieder gibt, weil ich bin faul. Ja, ich gehe, ich hau ab, Leute, macht's gut, haut rein, ich bin raus für heute, ansonsten viel nach, dass ihr mit dabei wart. Ne, ich bin raus, macht's gut, tschüss. Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, kommt gut da durch. Kommt gut raus aus der letzten Woche und kommt gut rein in die nächste Woche, guter Übergang. Wir wünschen euch da irgendwie viel Erfolg und nehmt es nicht so schwer.
Ciao, tschüss, macht's gut.